[Música]
hay un leve retroceso en la inflación en
eeuu que tan bueno que tan positivo
puede ser este dato se lo preguntamos a
jorge hurtado de la redacción de
economía de france 24 bienvenido jorge
hablamos de este tema de la reducción de
la inflación en eeuu bueno santiago los
que se mantuvo sin cambios prácticamente
en la relación de junio a julio de la
inflación interanual en estados unidos
luego del 9,1 por ciento de junio el
máximo de cuatro décadas la inflación
anual se ubicó en 8,5 por ciento en
julio el primer mes en mucho tiempo en
lo que los precios no han subido según
la oficina de estadísticas laborales de
ese país los precios subieron por una
serie de factores como los bloqueos en
las cadenas de suministros mundiales los
estímulos masivos del gobierno a
principios de la pandemia del cobi 19 y
la invasión de rusia en ucrania pero lo
que sí se ha mantenido al alza son los
precios de otros rubros como alimentos
alquiler automóviles y servicios médicos
pese a este respiro a esta tregua queda
la economía la bajada de los precios es
impredecible cuánto tiempo va a durar
bueno y ahora hablamos de los acreedores
extranjeros que congelaron por dos años
la deuda de ucrania santiago los pagos
son de casi veinte mil millones de
dólares en bonos internacionales sin
señales de paz o de un alto al fuego en
el horizonte casi seis meses después del
inicio de esta invasión rusa los
tenedores de alrededor del 75 por ciento
del total de circulación aceptaron la
propuesta de kiev de congelar esa deuda
el valor del mercado de la deuda de
ucrania se ha desplomado en más de un 80
por ciento desde que comenzó la
acumulación de tropas rusas en las
fronteras a finales del 2021 debido a
que ucrania se enfrenta a una
contracción económica estimada hasta el
45% para este año los acreedores
bilaterales entre los que se encuentra
estados unidos reino unido y japón-
también respaldaron esa propuesta de
retraso del pago de la deuda pasamos
ahora a hablar de áfrica hablamos de
sierra leona en donde las protestas por
los precios de los combustibles se
volvieron violentas allí en las calles
de freetown la capital bueno esto está
estas manifestaciones terminaron en
enfrentamiento entre las fuerzas de
seguridad y grupos de jóvenes que
exigían la dimisión del presidente
presidente mohamed uld el anuncio un
toque de queda en todo el país para
tratar de contener esas manifestaciones
los 8 millones de habitantes de sierra
leona viven una de las naciones más
pobres del mundo que ocupa el puesto 182
de 189 países en el índice de desarrollo
humano de naciones unidas' en julio el
país suprimió 30 de su moneda en un
intento de restablecer la confianza en
este país que ha sido principalmente
afectado por la inflación y pasamos a
españa en europa que comenzó allí un
plan de ahorro energético para cumplir
con ese pedido de la unión europea en
qué consiste el plan bueno este plan que
fue aprobado la semana pasada generó
muchísima controversia social y política
por la oposición de regiones gobernadas
principalmente por la derecha pero
cuáles son las medidas lo preguntamos a
nuestra corresponsal marina colorado y
nos cuenta más en el siguiente reporte
comienza la carrera de ahorro de gas del
7 establecido para españa' después del
acuerdo alcanzado con la unión europea
para
disminuir los efectos de la guerra en
ucrania en el país hoy miércoles 10 de
agosto entran en vigor algunas de las
restricciones impuestas por el gobierno
de pedro sánchez entre ellas el uso del
aire acondicionado y de la calefacción
el aire acondicionado durante los meses
de verano no podrá estar por debajo de
los 27 grados celsius aunque hay algunas
excepciones como por ejemplo en
restaurantes son lugares como mercados
de comida donde la seguridad alimentaria
tiene que mantener una temperatura
definida y en los meses de invierno la
calefacción no podrá estar por encima de
los 19 grados además de estas
restricciones hoy también entra en vigor
el cierre el apagado perdón de los del
alumbrado en edificios públicos y de los
escaparates que a partir de las 10 de la
noche
tendrán que estar apagados siempre y
cuando no quede gente en su interior
estas medidas estarán en vigor hasta
noviembre del año que viene de 2000 el
30 de septiembre además entran otras
medidas en vigor como por ejemplo el
cierre de puertas en establecimientos
que no podrán dejar que la energía se
desperdicie tanto el aire acondicionado
como la calefacción por tener como por
ejemplo este establecimiento las puertas
abiertas tendrán que tener un sistema
aunque sea rudimentario para evitar el
despilfarro de energía aunque provenga
de fuentes renovables todo esto con
todas estas medidas de restricción el
gobierno de pedro sánchez pretende
reducir su consumo de gas entre un 4 y
un 5 por ciento cambian un poco las
prácticas rutinarias de los españoles de
indicadores como las de las bolsas bueno
empezamos en eeuu el euro subió las
acciones de wall street también subieron
el dólar cayó después de que estas
señales de desaceleración de la
inflación en eeuu impulsarán las
apuestas de que la reserva federal de
ese país subiría los tipos de interés a
un ritmo un poco más lento de lo que lo
ha venido haciendo en europa las
acciones subieron ya que estos datos
también de una leve caída de la
inflación en eeuu animaron a los
inversores en américa latina la bolsa
mexicana de valores avance 1,2 por
ciento en su principal indicador como
reacción favorable de los inversionistas
sobre los datos de inflación en eeuu que
su principal socio comercial muchas
gracias jorge por estos datos de la
jornada económica del día de hoy a
continuación el debate en directo
américa
[Música]